you know I've gotten a lot of questions
and comments on Twitter in the last two
or three weeks with all the government
stuff going on and Obamacare or
launching and all of those kinds of
things if you know that I'm pretty much
a I'm pretty much a capitalist Pig I'm a
capitalist I believe in capitalism and
people are always they don't understand
why because Dave you're for the little
guy Dave you're out there you're a
consumer advocate you're the one that
protects the people who've gotten beat
up and beat down and so why would you be
for capitalism because I'm a pragmatist
I'm practical I believe in things that
work that's what a pragmatist is and if
you're too much of a pragmatist you can
do things that work even if they're not
moral and so we don't wanna go that far
obviously and capitalism can take the
form of amoral meaning where people in
their freedom use it to mistreat people
rather than use their freedoms to help
people but let me help you with this
folks the United States of America is
the largest group of wealthy people ever
in the history of the world the largest
group of wealthy people ever in the
history of the world here's some
statistics for you if you make household
income of thirty four thousand dollars
you're in the top 1% of income earners
in the world if you make eleven thousand
dollars a year which puts you
substantially below the poverty line
you're in the top 14 percent of people
in the world income wise this is the
largest group and you're one of them if
you're listening to me the largest group
of wealthy people see we think wealthy
people are millionaires but now if you
make $34,000 a year household income
you're in the top 1% of income earners
in the world now why is it that the
United States of America in spite of all
of our warts
our flaws has reached that point was it
just luck was it random now it's a
combination of two things
freedom / capitalism three things if you
want to get technical freedom in
capitalism but freedom and capitalism
undergirded by oh by our judeo-christian
ethic so whether you believe in God or
whether you're a person of faith or not
really doesn't matter in this discussion
right now you are still the benefit a
the beneficiary of a group of people who
do here's what I mean the very essence
of our legal system is biblically based
the very essence of our economic system
is biblically based and the very essence
of capitalism when it's done right is
biblically based translation you tell
the truth and you serve people of faith
have worship service customer companies
who win have customer service service
serving is at the core of capitalism
when it's done properly and it is done
properly more times than it is not done
properly it doesn't make the news when
someone does a great job waiting on the
table but if you go out to a nice
restaurant and the waiter the server
does a great job
you leave appreciation in the form of a
tip in the form of profit when someone
fixes your heating and air you
appreciate them for doing that and you
pay them for the work which includes
profit that they use to feed their
family and put braces on their kids and
pay for their kids college and buy a car
so once
one serves and someone tells the truth
those are judeo-christian ethics that
doesn't stand true for all forms of
faith and it doesn't stand for true for
all cultures that judeo-christian ethic
underpinning of telling the truth and
serving combined with the freedoms that
we've had in this country and combined
with capitalism listen to this carefully
gives the little man the best shot that
he's ever had in the history of the
world I know this because I'm the little
man
when Sharon and I got married we were
broke we had nothing I became a
millionaire by the time I was 26 years
old I was so stupid I lost everything I
had to do it twice
some of you only have to do it once I
talked to a guy the other day that had
several million dollars in his mutual
funds he was 70 years old he never made
over $70,000 in his lifetime but he
invested and saved in mutual funds every
single month he was a plumber capitalism
gives the little man the best shot at
not only survival but at prosperity in
the history of the world no time can you
find where communism has done that where
the government provides everything and
evens everything out and everyone gets
an economic trophy everyone's the same
we all have the same clothes we all have
the same cars we all have the same jobs
and the government is the owner that's
communism and one step in between that
and capitalism is called socialism where
the government provides you a lot of
things too many things that it can't
afford to do so capitalism is far
superior for you and for me so that's
why I prefer capitalism if you don't fit
believe me visit several of the
wonderful countries we call romantic in
Europe and look at their economic
systems and look at how the people are
doing it's not really very romantic
honestly pretty much sucks this is the
Dave Ramsey show